the story at Roosevelt Park with the
Corktown neighborhood is connected to
the story of the construction of the
Michigan central train station the train
station opened on December 26 1913 and
the structures on the future park were
meant to be gone by then but they
weren't because the residents who were
living there resisted the displacement
about 100 structures remained in front
of the train station in the 19-teens
some of them were abandoned some of them
were occupied so there was a huge
struggle in the newspapers in the courts
in the public arena and it culminated in
some pretty horrific removal tactics
this was in 1918 there were three
structures that still stood on 15th
Street very close to the train station
about 20,000 people marched alongside a
British Army tank named Britannia as it
rolled down Michigan Avenue turned on
15th Street and tore through the houses
so that was how the park was finally
demolished what we're researching at
Roosevelt Park is the history of this
displaced community what happened during
the displacement process was is there
any archaeological evidence of the
resistance they also want to know more
about the neighborhood and the families
who lived there before the condemnation
suit and before the displacement began
and these are families who were
working-class they came from a variety
of different occupations a variety of
different ethnicities and their stories
are not told in the his
Detroit my name is Chris DeRose esky and
I'm an archaeologist at Wayne State
University all right let's get to work
the things that people threw away a
hundred years ago or in many ways just
as mysterious as the things that people
threw away in ancient Egypt three four
or five thousand years ago because often
what people say they do and what they
actually do are two very very different
things so the students who are
excavating at Roosevelt Park are
focusing on the private areas of
household activities the backyards of
the houses the privies and the outhouses
and the outbuildings Lauren is scraping
back the soil layer here and even in
uniform fashion using a trowel we use
trowels or flat shovels to kind of
maintain spatial control and a
horizontal level over the excavation
unit every soil layer that's
distinguished from layers above or below
it by different textures or different
soil colors has a number we call it a
context number so what they have on the
bags is a label that tells us the
archaeological context the fine spots
well this all gets picked up put in this
bucket and then we'll take it over to
our screening station and we have an
artifact sieve so they're looking for
any any artifacts any architectural
materials nails small brick fragments
personal effects the fragments that we
have to work through are essentially
puzzle pieces and to fit together those
puzzle pieces we need to work with
objects themselves the historical
documents and also define to spot the
soil context of the objects how they
relate to the soil how they relate to
the buildings that they were next to
look at that
I see yeah you do this is a medicine
bottle this would have had like some
sort of pill or elixir in it and we did
some research background research on the
bottle and we found that this particular
bottle dates to 1910 this barometer and
product was advertised as a hair dye for
women the advertisement is speaking
directly to working women and it's
encouraging them to look suitable for
the workplace by getting rid of their
gray hair gray hair was not acceptable
in the early 20th century workplace
especially for women so that was really
exciting for us because it signaled that
there was a female in the household that
we were excavating who was working
perhaps so that's something we'll follow
up and do more research on now at
Roosevelt Park we started asking
questions at the neighborhood level but
we found so many artifacts about 10,000
artifacts so far that we're starting to
learn more about the families who lived
there we found a doll head with
decoration on it and a doll leg from lot
four we also found marbles from that
same excavation unit and toys right next
door to it in the lot three excavation
unit that tells us that there were
children living on this property in the
1880s and 1890s and now we can go back
to the census records actually see the
names of those children how long they
lived for were they suffering from any
medical conditions we can trace them
through other school records
looking at Detroit today through the
lens of archaeology we're able to
realize that Detroit is not a blank
slate that's to be built upon with brand
new things that don't connect with
Detroit's past because so many people in
Detroit have tangible connections to
where their family used to live but they
don't want the memory of these places
destroyed so archaeology not only has a
role in preserving the cultural
resources and public history of the city
but it has a role in the future making
of Detroit
I study a group of scorpions that bond
to the genus centroid these commonly
known as the bark scorpions and they
make venom that is intensely painful
some people describe it as the feeling
or sensation of being burned with a
cigarette or being branded and that
could be followed by a sensation you
feel like somebody's hit you with a
hammer hopefully the weather will hold
could rain might be beautiful might not
get over 100 it's always a it's a gamble
but